-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
You guys, this is very exciting.
Tomorrow is the annual lighting
of the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
The Christmas tree lighting
is kind of like prom night.
There's tons of buildup and
then it's over in one second.
[ Laughter ]
I heard that the tree will be
topped by a giant star
that has 3 million crystals.
[ Audience oohs ]
I love that New York locks up
the deodorant at CVS and then
leaves 3 million crystals
in the middle of the street.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, I saw that the tree
lighting ceremony could actually
be affected by heavy rain
and wind gusts up to
50 miles an hour.
[ Audience ohs ]
You know earlier when I said
I was excited for
the tree lighting, I didn't
mean it, but now I am.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's where you want to
be during a massive storm.
Under an 80-foot tree with a
9-foot star and no root system.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Suddenly Mario Lopez is yelling,
"Timber!"
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry, if the weather gets
really bad, NBC has a plan.
They're just going to air
last year's tree lighting
because it looks the same.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The exact same.
That's right, tomorrow is
the Christmas tree lighting
in Rockefeller Center,
but tonight we thought
we'd also do something special.
We've never done this before.
Tonight we present to you,
the first annual lighting
of the beard!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Roots, can I get
some holiday music?
And let's bring down the lights
for a second here.
♪♪
Alright, let's count it down.
3, 2, 1.
Happy holidays.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
-The lighting of the beard
is brought to you
by Terry's Steaks.
Terry's Steaks -- makes you say,
"Mmm, that kinda tastes
like beef!"
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Here's some good news.
Today is Giving Tuesday.
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah.
That's right.
[ Applause ]
It's a day of generosity
when millions of people give
to their favorite charities
or struggling organizations.
Which explains why Twitter
was trending all day.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
today is Giving Tuesday.
I love giving, especially
on Giving Tuesday,
but of course there's one thing
I'm not going to give.
-Really? What's that?
-It's just something
I'm never going to give.
-Well, what is it?
-I, Jimmy Fallon, am never...
[ Note plays ]
♪ Gonna give you up,
never gonna let you down ♪
♪ Never gonna run around
and desert you ♪
You got Rick Roll'd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That Rick Roll was brought
to you by Terry's Steaks.
Terry's Steaks -- makes you say,
"Mmm, that kinda tastes
like beef!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-People were talking about this.
Last year, several Oscar
categories were cut
from the live telecast,
and everyone was outraged.
So the Academy just announced
that this year,
all 23 Oscar categories
will be presented live.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
That should be fun.
All the length of a Marvel movie
with none of the excitement.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, some big sports news.
Today the U.S. beat Iran 1-0
to advance to the next round of
the World Cup.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
U.S.A.!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
I just hope this doesn't ruin
our incredible friendship
with Iran.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we're on to
the next round.
Americans haven't been
this fired up about soccer
since we remembered
it existed last week.
[ Laughter ]
When asked how they beat Iran,
the U.S. coach said,
"We found their secret game plan
in a box at Mar-a-Lago."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the second week of
the World Cup started today.
The games have been so fun
to watch that we've actually
started playing a little soccer
around the office.
Tariq, you ready for this?
-Yeah, man, pass it to me.
-Alright. Here we go, bud.
[ Audience oohs ]
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Ooh!
[ Alarm blares ]
-Murder robot activated.
-Does anyone know
the Heimlich maneuver?
[ Audience ohs ]
He's still choking!
Oh, nice.
[ Alarm blares ]
-Dance robot activated.
-2, 1.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! It's fun.
Well, get this, a temple
in Thailand dismissed
all their monks because they
just tested positive for meth.
[ Laughter ]
Which explains the new hit show
in Thailand,
"Breaking Buddhist."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
it is time for "WeTweet"!
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets.
We're all going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there.
You can vote for all of them,
if you like.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
We're going to see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers?
-Got it.
-Alright. Very good.
Whichever gets the most likes,
we're gonna tweet it out,
so you can all like it
and wetweet it.
[ Laughs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, guys,
you ready for this?
-[ Cheers ]
-Alright.
And be kind. It's the holidays.
Okay, here we go.
The first tweet is...
-Wow.
-Yeah, just dead silence.
[ Laughter ]
Not even a titter.
-Not even a titter.
-Not even a titter for Twitter.
-Not even a golf applause.
-Nothing on that one. Alright.
I think the votes are
probably in on this one.
Let's see the results.
Yeah.
-Whoa!
[ Sad tuba ]
Wow! 132.
-Not everyone even voted on
that.
-No. They said, "We're good.
No thanks."
-"Jimmy, we're here for
the commercial breaks."
[ Laughter ]
-Want more Terry's Steaks.
-This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
It's all -- Every page.
Some weird -- Yeah.
-Neon blue.
-Smurf.
-Windex.
-Yeah, Windex.
Smurf, whatever they want.
Yeah, here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
I think this one
will fare better.
Alright. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-112.
-Yeah.
-Tough crowd. Very honest.
Very honest.
It doesn't really matter,
I should also let you know.
[ Laughter ]
This next one here says...
-Come on.
-I don't want to go there.
It's too much work.
-How is Jim?
-Oh, he's doing well.
Let's see the results here.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew that.
I appreciate that.
So they do work.
The clickers do work.
Alright, that's real.
I love this. Alright. Fun.
This is good.
That might be --
-That might be the winner, 171.
-I think it definitely is
going to be the winner.
Alright, let's see.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Would you like a black one?
-Please.
Do you have a blue one?
-We don't have black markers.
-What do you have?
-We have blue.
-I'm good.
-Okay.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah. Wow.
[ Crowd booing ]
-[ Sad tuba ]
-No, you can't boo. No, stop.
Don't play that. Don't boo.
They're all fun.
-Well, that tweet was
the Pepsi of this round.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Alright. This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow!
-This is just
my favorite sweater.
How dare you?
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-That's the winner right there,
everybody.
By one vote.
Ugly Christmas sweater.
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet, and enjoy.